so the other day we're driving the car
and i said hey tico dylan i keep saying
tico's name is patrick but patrick
dillon
said yeah daddy i said so
what are you guys going to do long term
you guys going to be in business with
your daddy are we going to do business
together
they look at each other mario you
remember this i'm already somewhere
around here
he says well that that's a pretty deep
question we got to get back to you on
that
yes or no mario where are you i'm like
you got to be i'm like oh i'm sorry yeah
sure you know so i'm driving i'm like
damn mario that was a deep response
so 10 minutes later we're still driving
and said daddy we thought about it
what's that buddy
me and tika are going to start a
business together we want to run
businesses together ourselves that's
what we're gonna do but not with you but
we're gonna do it ourselves
i'm like
freaking awesome
because it's now your kids dreams now
it's you your spouse and that one
individual kid then it's your kids
together what they're gonna be doing